to put it mildly Harley Quinn's
relationship with the Joker has been
fraught but as she's evolved over the
years Harley has become so much more
than a victim here's a look at the
colorful and complicated relationship
between the Joker and Harley Quinn
she's one of DC's most famous characters
today but Harley Quinn was never meant
to be such a big deal The Joker's crazy
and love sidekick was created to fill a
small role in Joker's gang in Joker's
favor a 1992 episode of batman the
animated series writer producer Paul
Dini came up with Quinn's persona when
he saw actress Arleen Sorkin in an
episode of long-running soap opera days
of our lives and took some inspiration
for his new henchmen Erick tur I am
Calliope the court jester I performed at
the knight of the round table Bar and
Grill just a fortnight ago Harley was
also clearly inspired by the various
hench women on the 1966 Batman TV show
and you can see other parallels in her
debut episode Quinn wears multiple
disguises and sets off a 60 style
paralyzing gas bomb during a testimonial
dinner for Commissioner Gordon at the
Joker's behest
she's also clearly smitten with the
Joker from day one and the little
interactions between the two really
struck a chord with viewers before long
the showrunners knew that they had a
potential hit on their hands
Quinn was featured in more episodes and
became the Joker's love interest
something that Dini and his co-creator
artist Bruce Timm were initially wary of
because they didn't want a romance to
detract from the Joker's sinister
creepiness ironically Quinn's
introduction would ultimately propel the
Joker to all new levels of creep after
featuring her in a handful of episodes
of Batman the Animated Series Dini found
himself wanting to know more about
Harley Quinn viewers were responding
well to Harley and Dini soon realized
that she needed a backstory worthy of
the hype after deciding who she was
behind her mess and where she came from
the show began to hint at a much deeper
backstory look when I was a doctor I was
always listening to other people's
problems then I met mr. J listen to me
rich fans got the full lowdown on the
origin of Harley Quinn and the Joker's
relationship in 1993 when the one-shot
the Batman adventures Mad Love was
released to critical acclaim Dini and
Tim's Eisner award-winning
Tomek which was set in the TV shows
continuity revealed exactly how Quin
became the Joker's girlfriend in it an
ambitious psychiatrist named dr. Harleen
Quinzel takes a job at the notorious
Arkham Asylum where the Joker is being
held she tries to help him but it's the
Clown Prince of Crime who ends up
getting inside her head after the Joker
escapes Arkham and is apprehended by
Batman a head-over-heels Quinzel
transforms herself into a gesture like
villain and stages of breakout with that
harley quinn was born and so was her
abusive manipulative relationship with
the Joker in 1999 Mad Love was adapted
virtually shot-for-shot into an episode
of the animated series and later that
year Harley Quinn would be formally
added to the mainstream DC Universe in a
self-titled comic with her own series
following shortly after in 2001 when DC
revamped its entire line of comics in
2011 with an all-new universe as the new
52 the origin of the Joker and Harley
Quinn's toxic relationship went through
a few changes the alteration might seem
subtle on the surface but for many
Harley Quinn fans the new 52 version of
the character was totally different at
the core in Dini and Tim's original Mad
Love Harley falls in love with the Joker
during their therapy sessions and while
the Joker does manipulate her feelings
for him she joins his ranks willingly
that's not the case in the new 52 in the
updated origin story The Joker pushes
Quinzel into a vat full of the same
chemical that bleached his skin white
and turned him insane and he does so
against her will for many this
fundamentally changed who Harley Quinn
was as a character altering her agency
and the whole nature of her relationship
with the Joker
David iers Suicide Squad film featured a
mix of both origins with Margot Robbie's
Quinzel taking an oath to the Joker and
jumping into the VAT herself but only
after being manipulated and literally
having her brain jilted with
electroshock therapy what are you gonna
do you're gonna kill me mr. J what
oh I'm a dick area I'm just gonna hurt
ya the jokerz relationship with Harley
Quinn has been both physically and
emotionally abusive from the very
beginning the Clown Prince of Crime
routinely lashed out at Quinn in Batman
the Animated Series often with acts of
violence that were particularly shocking
for a show primarily aimed at children
the animated Mad Love in particular can
be difficult to watch due to its vicious
portrayal of the Joker's abuse there are
a few instances where the violence is
played for slapstick comedy like a
lingerie wearing Harley getting shoved
off a desk and cartoonishly kicked out
in the beginning as the show goes on
though it turns much more serious and
when Harley commits the ultimate sin of
nearly killing Batman herself in an
effort to impress the Joker his response
is presented as horrifyingly realistic
consequences that we rarely see in
cartoons the message is clear if Harley
was just a funny side character at the
beginning she's something very different
once we know her story when got a new
more revealing look for popular 2009
video game Batman Arkham Asylum but her
relationship with the Joker stayed the
same in fact the idea that the Joker is
Quinn's abuser was drilled home during
the game's dialogue by none other than
the Joker himself in the Joker's party
cutscene the villain casually refers to
his physical abuse of Harley as a hobby
beating a bane feeding scarecrow to croc
swapping around Holi my hobby by the way
the Joker often gets upsettingly
physical with Harley Quinn in the comics
he's done everything from
pistol-whipping hurt to kicking her in
the face but from time to time he goes
one step further and actually tries to
end her life Harley's first mainstream
DC Universe appearance for example came
in the 1999 one-shot batman Harley Quinn
written by the characters co-creator
Paul Dini in that story the Joker tries
to off his girlfriend with the
over-the-top method of launching her
into space in a rocket the thing is it's
not because she's too overbearing but
because he's becoming too attached to
her for his liking the very idea of
having affection for someone is so
off-putting to the Clown Prince of Crime
that he decides to end it permanently
sadly things haven't gotten any better
for Harley since then they've only
gotten more very
the 2016 Suicide Squad film was a highly
divisive movie pulling in just shy of
750 million at the worldwide box office
despite the fact that the vast majority
of critics trashed it if there was one
thing that everyone could agree on
though it was that margot robbie stole
the show as Harley Quinn fears that the
character was going to become a punching
bag for Jared Leto's Joker turned out to
be largely unfounded
although it took a last-minute change of
heart from the studio it seems as though
Warner Brothers got wise to a possible
backlash and decided to make the Joker's
relationship with his girlfriend a
little less abusive according to Leto
the studio cut so many Joker scenes out
of Suicide Squad that they could have
stitched them all up in a separate Joker
movie when the scenes leaked online the
reason for leaving them on the cutting
room floor eventually became abundantly
clear they were way too violent for what
was ultimately a pg-13 movie especially
where Joker and Harley were concerned in
addition to what was left out entirely
the crazy couples big helicopter rescue
scene was reportedly reshot in the final
cut Quinn falls from the chopper after
it gets hit but reports suggest that the
Joker tossed Quinn out of the moving
helicopter during a heated argument in
the original cut most versions of Harley
Quinn are dangerously obsessed with
their respective versions of the Joker
but the cupid of crime has actually been
involved with a number of other
characters in her relatively short
history Quinn had a thing going with her
Suicide Squad teammate Deadshot at one
stage something that was hinted at
through their connection in the
live-action movie things got super weird
between the two in the 7th issue of the
new 52 Suicide Squad when Quinn tied the
sharpshooter to a chair and draped
Joker's actual severed face which the
Joker had removed himself from his own
skull because you know he's the Joker
over Deadshot's face for a little
therapeutic role-playing things got
pretty dark but you probably already
guessed that from hearing about the
Joker's severed face Harley's
relationship with poison ivy is a lot
more uplifting fans started wondering if
there might be some romantic feelings
between them way back in the 1990's ivy
was always critical of Quinn's toxic
relationship with the Joker in Batman
the Animated Series and in the years
that followed their own relationship
blossomed DC confirmed that they were
girlfriends without the jealousy of
monogamy in a 2015 tweet and in 2017 s
Harley Quinn number
25 they shared their first main universe
kiss in fact 2017 was a pretty busy year
for Quinn in terms of her love life
she got a smooch from both the Green
Lantern and interstellar tough guy Lobo
in the spin-off series appropriately
titled Harley's little black book and
the animated version of the character
climbed into bed with that family member
Nightwing much to the Dark Knight's
disapproval their steamy scene in the
animated feature film Batman in Harley
Quinn left many fans and Batman himself
in shock would harley quinn be able to
have a normal relationship with the
Joker if he wasn't completely deranged
that question was answered in Batman
white night a limited series from DC's
Black Label Line in which she got the
love story she always wanted with the
Joker beginning in 2017 writer artist
Sean Murphy's a tissue comic features a
sane version of the Joker cured by a
miracle drug his real name it turns out
is Jack Napier and he's hell-bent on
redemption which he seeks out by running
for City Council and even turning
against Gotham's other villains it's not
just Gotham's forgiveness that he's
after however the repentant villain also
wants to make amends with his former
lover and he gets down on one knee to
prove it the only problem is that this
Harley isn't actually Harley after all
after the Joker went too far by
torturing Robin Harley left him only to
be replaced with an all-new
all-different Harley Quinn named Mary
Andrews and he forgot all about it fake
Harley freaks out at the marriage
proposal and attacks Napier but the
actual Harley dressed in her classic red
and black getup as opposed to Marian's
more movie style gear shows up and
rescues him kicking her doppelganger in
the head for good measure romantic right
with Jack cured Harley gets her
long-awaited romance oh and in case you
were wondering Mary Andrews is actually
a reference to marry Andrew an archaic
name for a clown which means it's
actually a worst pun than the Harley
Quinn take on Harlequin the movie birds
of prey and the fantabulous emancipation
of one harley quinn drove home the idea
that Harley Quinn is done with the Joker
it seems as though there were plans to
show their breakup on-screen at one
stage leaked set photos showed the
villain being kicked to the curb during
the filming of one scene that presumably
would have been at the start of the
movie but Jared Leto's Joker didn't even
appear outside of a brief animated
sequence
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah when she sat down for an interview
with Empire magazine in December 2019
margot robbie revealed that quinn would
be free to be who she wants to be in her
second movie appearance but independence
doesn't come easy to her
according to Robbie she's applying a
more complex take on the break-up than
the neat tidy ending that some viewers
may have wanted so is the movie version
of Harley Quinn fully over the Joker
well maybe but it might take a few more
movies to get all that puddin out of her
system check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite characters
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you